بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
اصحاب السمو اصحاب المعالي
السيدات والساده الحضور الكريم السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
يسرني اليوم
ان اكون متواجدا معكم
لاطلاق احد اهم مشاريع الرياضه
ونسعد
بهذه الاطلاق النوعيه
التي شرفنا بها سمو سيدي ولي العهد
كرياضيين اليوم باطلاق الاستثمار والتخصيص
للانديه الرياضيه
والذي يعد نقله النوعيه
وتاريخيه للرياضه السعوديه
تقودنا الى تحقيق المزيد
المزيد من التميز المنشود للمنتخبات
الوطنيه
والانديه الرياضيه على كافه الاصعده
بدايه باسمي ونيابه عن كل الرياضيين اتقدم
بعظيم الشكر
وبالغ الامتنان لمولاي خادم الحرمين
الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز
ولسيدي صاحب السمول الملكي الامير محمد بن
سلمان بن عبد العزيز حفظهما الله
على ما تجده كافه القطاعات والقطاع
الرياضي على وجه الخصوص
من دعم واهتمام مستمر اثمر عن قفزات نوعيه
وكبيره
حرص قيادتنا ودعم واهتمام سمو سيدي ولي
العهد حفظه الله
مكننا في القطاع الرياضي من اطلاق العديد
من المبادرات الكبيره التي مهدت الطريق
لهذا المشروع التاريخي
فاستراتيجيه دعم الانديه ومشروع نافس كان
لهما الاثر الكبير في تمكين القطاع الخاص
من الاستثمار في القطاع الرياضي
وتهيئه البيئه المناسبه لهذا المشروع الذي
سيحدث نقله غير مسبوقه في رياضه المملكه
ان شاء الله
في عام 2019 بدات استراتيجيه دعم الانديه
الرياضيه والتي تم من خلالها تطوير
الحوكمه والهيكل والهيئه كل التنظيميه
والاداريه والماليه داخل الانديه حيث نجح
اكثر من 61 نادي في تطبيق معايير الحوكمه
كما وصل عدد الانديه التي انشات شركات
خاصه للاستثمار الرياضي الى 13 نادي وان
شاء الله الى مزيد من الانديه في المستقبل
وزاد عدد الانديه التي فعلت عشر رياضات
واكثر من تسعه انديه في عام 2019
الى 110 في عام 2023
وارتفعت ايرادات الانديه من الرعاه من 88
مليون ريال في موسم 2019 الى 728 مليون
ريال في موسم 20 23
كما ضاعف كما تضاعف عدد الرياضيين من
اربعين الف رياضي ورياضيه عام 2019 الى 81
الف عام عشرين ثلاثين عشرين 23
في الرياضات المحدده ضمن مبادره الالعاب
المختلفه في استراتيجيه الدعم الانديه
وزاد الحضور الجماهيري من واحد فاصله واحد
مليون مشجع موسم 2019 الى اثنين فاصله
اثنين مليون مشجع في عام 203 وعشرين وتم
استحداث
3500 وظيفه بدواما كامل في الانديه
الرياضيه
اما مشروع نافس المعدي باصدار التراخيص
للانديه والاكاديميات والصلاه الرياضيه
فقط مكن القطاع الخاص من الاستثمار في
القطاع الرياضي بالمملكه
واتاح الفرصه للمستثمرين المحليين
والدوليين لتاسيس وتطوير انديه واكاديميات
وصالات رياضيه
حيث تم خلال هذه المنصه اصدار اكثر من
2700 رخصه حتى الان
منها 200191 رخصه لصلاه والمراكز الرياضيه
196 رخصه للانديه الرياضيه
361 رخصه للاكاديميات
62 رخصه لمراكز الغوص
ومن خلال منصه نافس ايضا
حصلت اربعه انديه تجاريه على رخص اتاحت
لها الفرصه للمشاركه في منافسات دوري
الدرجه الرابعه لكره القدم
هذه المبادرات وغيرها من الانظمه واللوائح
التي تم اقرارها في السنوات الماضيه
ساهمت في تطبيق اعلى معايير الحوكمه
والتنظيم الاداري والمالي في الانديه
الرياضيه
وصنعت فرصا استثماريه مميزه للقطاع الخاص
واليوم نتحدث عن المشروع الوطني الرياضي
الكبير
الذي نطمح من خلاله للمساهمه في مستهدفات
رؤيه السعوديه عشرين ثلاثين
مشروع الاستثمار والتخصيص للانديه
الرياضيه هذا المشروع قام على عدد من
الاهداف المهمه وهي
خلق فرص نوعيه وجاذبه وبيئه جاذبه
للاستثمار في القطاع الرياضي
رفع مستوى الاحترافيه والحوكمه والاستدامه
الماليه في الانديه الرياضيه
وكذلك تعزيز تنافسيه الانديه وتطوير
البنيه التحتيه لها لتقدم افضل الخدمات
للجماهير الرياضيه
وسنعمل باذن الله من خلال هذا المشروع
لتحقيق قفزات نوعيه في مختلف الرياضات
عبر عبر صناعه جيل متميز
والوصول بالدوري السعودي لقائمه افضل عشر
دوريات في العالم
اضافه الى زياده ايرادات رابطه الدوري
السعودي للمحترفين
لتصل الى اكثر من واحد فاصه ثمانيه مليار
ريال سنويا
ورفع القيمه السوقيه للدوري السعودي
للمحترفين الى اكثر من ثمانيه مليار ريال
سعودي
ويتضمن مشروع الاستثمار والتخصيص للانديه
الرياضيه مسارين
الاول
استثمار شركات كبرى وجهات تطوير تنمويه في
انديه رياضيه
مقابل نقل ملكيه الانديه اليها والثاني
طرح عدد من الانديه الرياضيه للتخصيص
بدايه من الربع الاخير من هذا العام 20 23
فيما يخص المسار الاول
وبعد قيام عدد من الجهات التنمويه
والشركات الكبرى ببحث الفرص الاستثماريه
في القطاع الرياضي
نعلن اليوم عن تحويل اربعه انديه الى
شركات
ونقل ملكيات هذه الشركات الى جهات تطوير
تنمويه وذلك على النحو التالي
نقل ملكيه نادي القادسيه الى شركه ارامكو
السعوديه
وكذلك نادي الدرعيه الى هيئه تطوير بوابه
الدرعيه ونادي العلا الى الهيئه الملكيه
لمحافظه العلى ونادي الصقور الى شركه نيون
[تصفيق]
كما يسرني ان اعلن عن استثمار صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه في اربعه انديه سعوديه
من خلال تحويلها الى شركات يملكها الصندوق
ومؤسسات ومؤسسه غير ربحيه لكل نادي
والانديه هي
الاتحاد الهلال والنصر
وسيتم وفقا لذلك
انشاء صندوق استثماري لكل شركه من شركات
الانديه الثمانيه
التي تم نقل الملكيتها
وايداع قيمه النادي في الصندوق الاستثماري
مقابل نقل الملكيه
ويهدف هذا الصندوق الاستثماري الى تحقيق
عوائد مستدامه لصالح الشركه
ويهدف وهذه الشركات الخاصه بالانديه
الاربعه ستكون ملكيتها موزعه وفق نسبا
محددا صندوق الاستثمارات العامه يمتلك
نسبه 75% من ملكيه كل شركه
وخمسه وعشرين في المئه ستكون مملوكه لكل
مؤسسه غير ربحيه
المؤسسه غير ربحيه تضم الاعضاء الحاليين
في الجمعيه العموميه للنادي والاعضاء
الجدد في المؤسسه
ويتم انتخاب مجلس اداره المؤسسه من قبل
اعضاء الجمعيه العموميه للمؤسسه
وبعد تشكيل المجلس يتم ترشيح عضوين اثنين
لعضويه مجلس اداره النادي يكون احدهما
رئيسا للمجلس
وبالتالي
سيصبح مجلس اداره شركه النادي مكونا من
عضوين يتم ترشيحما من قبل اعضاء مجلس
المؤسسه الغير ربحيه وخمسه اعضاء يتم
ترشيحها
يتم ترشيحهم من قبل صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه
اما المسار الثاني والخاص بطرح عدد من
الانديه الرياضيه للتخصيص فانه بالتنسيق
مع المركز الوطني للتخصيص
سيتم في المرحله الاولى اختيار انديه من
مختلف الدرجات
لطرحها للقطاع الخاص وذلك في الربع الاخير
من هذا العام 20 23
بناء على معايير سيتم الاعلان عنها قبل
فتره الطرح
ومواكبه لهذه النقله التاريخيه للرياضه
السعوديه المتمثله بهذا المشروع النوعي
يسر وزاره الرياضه ان تعلن عن اقرار
اللوائح التاليه
اللائحه المنظمه لمؤسسات اعضاء الانديه
الرياضيه
واللائحه الاساسيه للانديه الرياضيه
بنسختها المحدثه
كما اود ان اؤكد للجميع ان مشروع
استراتيجيه دعم الانديه بما يتضمنه من
برامج ومبادرات
سيستمر العمل فيه بما يخدم كافه الانديه
الرياضيه وفق الاليه المتبعه لضمان
استمرار حوكمتها وتنظيمها ماليا واداريا
ومن خلال هذا المؤتمر
نؤكد لشركائنا في القطاع الخاص
بان هذا المشروع يخلق فرصا استثماريه مهمه
ونوعيه
ونتطلع للاستفاده منها وتحقيق المصالح
المشتركه لجميع الاطراف
ختاما
باسمي ونيابه عن كل الرياضيين
اجدد الشكر والعرفان
لقائدنا الملهم سمو سيدي ولي العهد حفظه
الله
والذي بدعمه وطموحه وعزمه سنواصل العمل
الجاد لتحقيق النجاحات لرياضه الوطن
الغالي ان شاء الله
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]
طبعت المزيد
من رامز والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات